double album you love the double you are
so prolific another double album
look at you i got my band back best i
could and i just we want to make music
it's so it's the one thing we're good at
i mean we're fat at everything else
right you know but look all our heroes
right there elton john
paul mccartney you know they're all
playing in their 70s that's why i tell
the band like we got 20 years to go if
you want it
we have kids life is good let's just
keep making music like
it's the one dream we ever got right
like all the other stuff doesn't matter
just just make music
yeah in other words don't sit and worry
about sales don't worry about whether
people like it or
just keep making the music fans will
write me right you know they read a
review and the first thing the review
said was
well this isn't siamese dream oh like
hopefully 27 years ago buddy of course
it's not siamese dream it's 27 years ago
i'm a different person we're different
people
you know for 15 years i've had to hear
from people about what they think
smashing pumpkins is
which is really weird and they almost
always default to the sound they think
they have in their mind about the way
the band used to sound
and then every time i push forward the
songs that i think are best the fans
react and
everything goes amazing and so that's
what's happening now as i've kind of
pushed forward the stuff i thought fans
would react to and they've been
totally supportive yeah well i'm a fan
and i love the album and you're right it
doesn't sound like anything you did
before which i
actually appreciate i think it would be
boring if you did the same album over
and over again
social media created this loop that's
never existed before of people wanting
the same thing over and over again
i mean it was always like that for any
band that had success but it created
some other thing that was
almost unprecedented in the history of
the music business and i'm glad i fought
through it because now we're on the
other side of that
all i know is the smashing pumpkins new
album fear
available wherever music is sold